In the depths of our solar system there is
a suburb.
No… not that kind of suburb.
Instead of McMansions…This neighborhood
is home to ancient space rocks, the ominous
planet nine and clues about the formation
of the universe.
It’s called the Kuiper Belt.
It was named after a pioneering astronomer
who worked with Carl Sagan on a secret mission
to detonate a nuclear bomb on the moon.
But that’s another story.
The Kuiper Belt can be found beyond the farthest
planet from the sun which is why objects in
the belt are referred to as trans-Neptunian.
This is where you’ll find Pluto and some
of the other members of the Dwarf Planet Squad.
Most of the objects in the Kuiper Belt are
really really really old.
When the solar system formed billions of years
ago, the gravitational tug from the new planets
swept all surrounding objects into the sun
or out of the solar system.
But objects that were far enough away were
safe and they grouped together in orbit forming
the Kuiper Belt.
This region has, for the most part, been a
mystery to astronomers.
But they’re actively working to find out
if the Kuiper Belt contains secrets about
the formation of the solar system.
And if it is home to what many believe might
be the ninth planet which is sadly not Pluto.
Make sure to share this video with your friends!
And follow Galactic Glossary to see more crafts
in space.
In this video, you’ll learn the difference
between celestial rocks.
Thanks for watching!
You can catch more episodes of Space Crafts
right here.
In this episode, you’ll learn all about
the phases of the moon so you’ll know exactly
when look out for the next full moon.
Thanks for watching Seeker, don’t forget
to subscribe!